well this is a strange experience
usually when you're on a bus you don't
have to think about anything but you
can't help but look at every twist and
turn this bus is doing all nine tons of
it driving at 50 miles an hour and
clearly there is no hands on the wheels
right now let's have a look at this
there is a safety driver though Manning
proceedings uh just in case of any
glitches and if we just uh go further
back here as well we're on the fourth
Road Bridge weaving our way across from
Fife through to Edinburgh there is also
a person on here for the customer
experience handing out tickets as well
and Stagecoach are the operator to bumpy
ride uh let's chat to Sam here from
Stagecoach and how safe is this well the
the technology is very safe so it's been
10 years in development five years as
part of the project and millions and
miles of testing we need to build a
safety case for the technology which is
certified by the safety and cyber Ethics
Committee so absolutely
um and the first passengers on board as
well um do you think you're going to get
people coming on board given this is
fairly untested territory uh I'm
positive though we're about a novel
about you and we'll attract a lot of
passengers want to travel but in
autonomous bus and not not only the fact
that it's the world's first autonomous
boss uh but we are expecting to carry
about 10 000 passengers a week when the
service is fully up and running and
what's the point if you've got a driver
and you've got two members of staff on
board when before you were doing the job
with one person well it's about proving
the technology and part of the project
is about understanding how the
autonomous boss affects other people how
it affects the passengers and how it
affects other Road users so it's
important that we deliver the continual
high levels of safety that we contribute
towards environmental benefits that we
get from autonomous bus operation but
also enhance the customer experience
okay Sam from Stagecoach thanks very
much indeed and that says pulling back
in to the yard on this test run but will
get going on Monday for real on a 14
mile route from Fife to Edinburgh